welcome back to truths not true it's
true news we know that nothing everyone
[__] sure you idiot welcome back
anyway today is top story
ksi and Deji have fallen out not what we
want to see now friends are the lads
especially JJ obviously start with a lot
of gigs in the past got a lot of love
for him don't want to see this happening
in YouTube it's getting a bit too
serious for me yet me too if you aren't
sure how we got at this point how it all
started was so the sidemen to decide
meant only of Adeje child was thrown
under the bus by randolph and she didn't
like that too much around off then
responded to him and said at least I
have not everything how did the me on a
silver platter and run off to the
district and edgy did addition and ran
off to the district then round off hurry
up with everyone's reactions of ructions
of death trucks anyway randolph insulted
edgy first who dead she could have taken
that a bit better didn't have to get so
angry but said she's a bit of a kid some
names bless him you know it mean that in
a stupor but he can't be Randolph had
every right to respond to dead G after
that because dead she mentioned that
Randolph's her [__] and he's got why
he's got a wife or whatever
my granddaughter his name isn't actually
Randolph which really that Rianne GERD
the reindeer no I mean Donner and
Blitzen were furious at that so at that
point when Randolph responded to dead G
that was that that was all that needed
to be Randolph said seven wrote edgy
edgy said something about Randolph
Randolph says something back
because the reined is you see we're sort
of making this tracks at the time
because all of the other reindeer used
to laugh and call him names they never
let poor Randolph play the sidemen games
then one foggy Seidman Sunday
Randolph came to play he said Randolph
with your channel so small
won't you come on our video minute that
Randolph cause I'm gonna cover the lies
on this and make a dis truck he blows it
way out of proportion
and I think that to be fit around off I
respect the grind he's wanting applause
a YouTube channel of having a diss track
against a ten million subscriber YouTube
channel is good for your channel
I get that even if it is it their
channel by your own words should he not
have just left their G alone because
it's JJ's brother and JJ brought you
into this and you put them into a
clearly a very difficult position by the
end of this a bit of forethought
would have gone a long way so then he
makes this this truck yeah you must
repent agree I'm more of a man you ever
be literally more of a man yeah there's
more of his literally spitting [__] oh
yeah brackets by sheer mass sucked you
know what I mean when you're young
you're famous parents smart running dead
and parents don't they don't run
Randolph is coming out as the rapper
in this either he's done rap songs
before this he's not a youtuber who raps
right Randolph is more of a rapper who
does YouTube first guy to my knowledge
yeah so we have to hold them to a little
bit of a higher standard yes I find it
weird when you know that Professor Green
you're just a Walmart ksi you've got no
lies
I'm sitting on a toilet I'm having a
[__] it sounds like you're straining
call us your way yeah you can you can
rap
Andrew you've done well here drew if you
can call you that what was wrong with MC
drew what was wrong with MC Andy he can
rub two like lyrically but why I'm
saying is you know that tone of voice
yeah say good I find it like annoying a
little bit yeah he's better putting
words together the most is YouTube I
don't understand why he shot it in
someone's back garden though so deadly
then mix her up
start the water you're not gonna waste
Andrew
daddy's the most unintentionally funny
kid like you too mother I love it
I really like you stop it stop it please
bang I'm gonna [__] your wife like a
horse
now how many horses is Neji been [__]
but when you take that jion
there's no guidelines there's no roof
he's gonna stick do you know just take
it as far as the hustle I'm enough can
buy his Porsche now drive along and feel
and feel pretty happy with himself but
at the end of the day he's let a man
publicly say I'm gonna [__] your wife
like a horse to me you to be future
drama or no drama if someone says that
you're getting slapped [__] and the
dress that's so mean
raw it that's collateral but I don't
agree with no that's what I'm saying
with dead you though this is what you're
getting into though isn't it what does
that say let me know when you're free if
you want to work on any music I'm always
up for it ah so who's trying to collab
and now I have a problem with people
saying that when you invite someone to
do something you're begging because
actually you came to me through the
podcast were you begging me to do the
podcast you should go look I was I knew
literally there was nobody else I know
although I wasn't friends with Chuck
mate then so good point yeah and I
wasn't friends with I'm Alex so maybe we
could have yeah could have both had a
plus-one
[Music]
so basically this is what set JJ off I
think is their bank statements from JJ
paying for the wedding four thousand
four thousand three thousand I mean
that's never gonna pay for a wedding
maybe a wedding in the North hiding like
he's an if that you means an Frank
who else famously hid you say what you
want about Ted she educated if this was
a white guy robbing hiding like his own
it would be so much worse it'll be so
much more controversial to be worse
though would yeah this was a young
Jewish girl hiding from the Nazis steady
is making himself the Nazis as he said
earlier side men got you gassed up not
like that right yeah that's in probably
joke that were making it to the final
cut beef probably would yeah he run
Frank Frank
hiding like I can't believe that this is
the [__] the main thing that he's
saying in this video the main thing that
you run hiding like he's odd Frank are
you mental des here on high
[Music]
well Smith must be thrilled with a
mention in this is no YouTube rewind
that's what will get you just let you
went Will Smith you're an actor Will
Smith went correct got me on that one
yeah can I just make the point yeah
nothing wrong with Anne Frank she was
not I just one point one point there is
no shame in hiding from Nazis no
absolutely no shame if a lot of Nazis
are chasing you yeah hide hide
definitely yeah don't try and fight back
the works yeah that's there's no shame
and the thing is no you're joking about
how ridiculous is we're making jabs
about Anne Frank her cell never again
fully recommends so much respect that
woman for what she did oh yeah and
obscene and edgy is now dead jeez now
doing his impression of a librarian
hello can I help you your room [__]
they kicked you out because you ain't
paying rent you couldn't find the cash
digits that are you at the salmon house
more than your with your wife that's
what I'm like it is part I'm like saying
yeah he's actually explaining lyrics
that were quite literal you're right I'd
be living in the sidemen house I took
your room [__] they kicked you out
because you were in paying rent just
explain that yeah we don't know son yeah
I lived at the sidemen house because
they kick kick Ted yeah you mentioned me
wife and it is actually Tory I'm staying
in this room everyone I know to have a
good dead G for getting views because of
date JJ I think Randolph's got the least
round to stand on it must be the side
men first they were first at the teeth
yeah huge teats at the time jokey then a
few although YouTube us FIFA YouTube as
you were
that's a GU John guy yeah Randolph goes
on Daniel and and corn yeah JJ he's got
his tits out and he's just all six of
them pop pop he's humping working milk
full of lack and they're just like ah in
the mouth
very racy a rapper clone another
apartment it's true this is a it's an
odd one I'm Frank bad lung that is weird
what alone he hates everything he's
about
he's a comedyshortsgamer those are three
words I love I feel like he's accusing
dead G of getting girls pregnant right
and then aborting the child meaning
meaning grunts a lot meaning can't I
mean that stuff oh yeah
to me that's something that I think
would be a traumatic experience for the
person on the other end of that with
Deji if that is true that's not only
desease dirty laundry's he's gone
that's that's a lot of people's day to
learn drew their dues literally soon
he's gonna [__] his wife like a horse
and that's true but I don't think those
I don't think those girls ever got into
this thinking I want to be part of a
diss track yeah no one knows no one
knows what they were thinking when they
had sex with dead you dead you basically
after the lust district from Randolph
said JJ was giving him the dirt he used
against him and that judge had sided
against dead G yeah Randolph and he
blocked a G on all social media yeah so
dad she went off I think that was an
extreme action from JJ but in the heat
of the moment I can understand why you
would feel like wronged because that's
his privacy
like if you're entitled to anything in
the world is privacy right and he wasn't
in that beef between Randolph and Deji
so they shouldn't have dug him out to
use it against each other he said it was
always gonna happen and Randolph should
have seen the position he was gonna put
to JJ in when he started this is it is
that's true but then is it also true to
say that if JJ is saying things runned
awful there's those things he's been
privy to should Randolph have run those
things but I'm spec on yay west with
Pusha T when he gave all that
information away about Drake they were
all friends no suddenly not friends what
happens this could have been solved but
in a few years I think if there wasn't
the current being dangled of YouTube
money
it would never have gotten ohand because
that's why the districts were me that's
why it's bigger and bigger and bigger
because it boosts your career when
you're having beef in that JJ might have
been the only person who could have
wanted them separately and said look
this isn't happening
yeah he might have done that more but if
he didn't it's because he just doesn't
want to get dragged into it but
unfortunately the inevitable is happened
now you know what's weird is and I know
we're making fun of them all it's fun to
watch me outside districts you can take
the piss over districts yeah because
they're silly oh these are all
individually nice guys do you know what
I mean that's what I find striking and
edgy and you'll see this year is more
emotional than the other guys and I
think that this is a this is real fire
here's the first lesson on today's true
news news true news hurt people hurt
people you can see when he's struggling
to talk how real this is
he's not just you can't react this he's
not no he's not especially not dead he's
not saying this just for the [__] of it
like this is quite he's short of breath
he's that [__] upset about it yeah not
stop with him that's probably from yet
ages ago and JJ is just like I just want
to have some time with mom and dad like
me and them and he's probably said to me
off the cuff all this [__] that you have
eye when you're related of someone it's
coming out
[Music]
I mean the Greek gods treated each other
terribly they were a lot of them are
related to by why are they doing this in
public what did she say and he's blocked
me and all social media blocked me on
text messages you send it to zurka send
it someone else and go can you show this
to JJ I think that a youtuber in them is
basically drama is cash so that if we're
gonna do this with me feel this way papi
let's put it out there the whole thing's
been started because of [__] online
because ultimately what do either than
lose from it nothing really
but the relationship could be streamed
and I think JJ would prefer to handle it
behind closed doors rejection is hard to
take though isn't it seems like he feels
quite rejected 100% rejection stares a
lot of horrible the most I think dead
she's like look I've just responded in a
beef I don't think I've done anything
that bad but obviously JJ felt betrayed
by the whole bank statement he's like
you know that's [__] and now because
JJ's block dead G it comes across like
he sided with JJ then put a tech a tweet
oh and he said look whatever happens I
love you
I'm sorry come he just sort of handle
this sort of thing dead she wasn't done
who was that
this is you might not remember him that
his Randall
yeah this is also Tim Allen in their
film Center he's not Randolph off the
roof and now he's slowly becoming
Randolph yeah although that's unfair and
OH
you can't compare YouTube rap to real
rappers I never do that
when you all day everyday just rap rap
rap like proper rappers do they're gonna
be on a level where it's just devoted to
that one thing that one art form and
that's why they're class of what they do
youtubers they do a lot of things and
they're just try in a rhyme and try to
put it to some music and trying them
best so you've got to judge it for what
it is but there's some there's some
decent stuff in yet yeah not too bad no
no it's not terrible gonna be this is
the state of play
Deji ends this [__] today up we're up
the date now by going on the logan paul
podcast what he's been on right i just
say after meeting me logan paul grows a
beard starts a podcast stay in your lane
and if you do win a game you have to
knock him off the roof right no not
another one of these like Logan must
feel it's checkmate when you get dead G
JJ's brother on your podcast withdraw JJ
another boss yeah like he must have
[__] thought Christmas come early
that's the perfect thing to get on the
Gog skin mmm isn't it what JJ publicly
appealed the deadly don't go on that
podcast on Twitter so we got daddy on
[Music]
Logan is little loving Logan Logan is
loving this like it's the ultimate
checkmate
for Logan this in a way getting dead G
on your podcast a slate changing I can't
imagine hopefully stop gog must be or if
this is all planned it's not slow this a
teenager
Lavinia JJ wouldn't plan this [__] you
would never allow that no [__] never
it's almost a constant state for JJ come
to in-n-out burger bat fault I'll tell
you above of me yeah yeah he rod hiding
like he's on that muffled baffled that
was the most baffling part of my wig i'm
almost constantly baffled by Deji I'll
be honest I've met a few people who have
complexes I've worked with some of the
most dumbest [__] alive ya think
that they know everything JJ does not
have a complex no but I can a hundred
percent tell you that I've spent little
time with him but you can see just from
the small amount of time you spend with
him he does not have a little tip for
Deji if you're trying to convince
everyone of some something don't go on
one of the biggest podcasts in the world
and say yeah it just didn't mean that
the whole point of the wrestling game
for example which is or boxing MMA or
whatever is you don't then admit it cuz
then you [__] yourself you don't you
don't see the rock going Stone Cold
Steve Austin is a punk [__] that was
good wasn't it yeah are you gonna buy it
you're gonna buy SummerSlam you gonna
buy this you are you coming to
Wrestlemania do I have to say more
basically we've got Deji slugging off JJ
on the log and pole podcast things I
never thought I would see Teddy's gone
rogue it's gotta be up there yeah bill
this another guy who considers himself
rapper first YouTube second is a lot
called queer Decker
I suppose he's an entertainer first
isn't he more of a rapper sec in the
words of javis basically JJ came out and
said he didn't react or deca yeah and
could I took that and run with it did a
diss truck Oh looks like a really nice
area there's actually not sure what's
with the eyes
don't know taking this many those oh we
already knew that yeah if you're gonna
make a GG diss record at this point just
give us something we don't not stop
talking about his [__] hairline all
right this guy is hanging out in a
neighborhood where you'd imagine there
are old people sort of again tweaking
the cut going what is that young man
doing in them vote one of the Desperate
Housewives called the police yeah
because man with the hood up out there
because you know when you film these
districts this is how it looks to people
through the window those are actually
the prerequisites to be one of the side
mens so absolutely now you do that in
the list look good right you're in you
can be a side man you're a list
awkward perfect you're in there's
nothing against this kid he's probably a
nice like lovely pink hoodie but you
know when someone discipline you're like
punchable yeah right can I can I can I
just show you the one thing that really
yeah it's that it's that [__] oh he
came out going what is I've got a lift
I'm awkward and I'm better than you
mmm it's so poor come on the floor is
our virtual lyrics on anything special
YouTube districts the first time Nick
happened were funny entertain and they
weren't trying to be anything special
but they were they were good for what
they were they were novel this time
round I [__] hit yeah I'm just gonna
put it out there I'm [__] here Mia
big spongebob fan big spongebob fan it
rhymes but like everyone's like well
it's hard that's hard people are
tweeting like oh this is hard Squidward
people are saying it's like it is not
NAS Izzy let's be I can we calm the [__]
down here now Donald Trump is cooler
than this kid
[Music]
regardless of what the [__] JJ says here
the one thing he's got going for him is
his tone of voice like I've talked about
Randolph's tone of voice I've talked
about that codec our kids Don he's got a
good sound was voice the way he says
glorious glorious we asked JJ for a
collab like everything could echo said
isn't as good as that the Macan
reference you know how I said dead she
and JJ are very different
occasionally they're quite similar yeah
hiding like she's on missing like
Madeleine yeah but it's it's the same as
much Oh JJ and the guild Fred you see
this is the thing because gingers well
known we know everything about them
listen so it looks like he's on earthing
[__] wait flex pay okay and so old but
it were table and what a new-age phone
so of like he's doing you know he's not
got a it didn't have a tractor anymore
he's sort of farming or is he making
tofu
what's this it feels like he'll think of
a word and you rather than trying to
stick to a theme he tries to think of
another word that rhymes with that and
then fill in the middle bit yeah so we
end up with things that anyway Pharma
said yeah you know it's either that or
he's writing in pencil but doesn't know
there's a rubber on the other end
I like when he says I don't need each
day I don't need to eat day that's
basically what they do and I'm a
celebrity because I am the two people oh
he means he is what everyone else rests
on things sometimes just sits at home
and goes I'm a [__] table I am the
[__] table I want to start using that
you had some good lines in here but
OnPoint is still to me that's the best
YouTube record so far so anyway that's
the YouTube this game right now
we hope that JJ and dad you can bury the
hatchet and unite again and hopefully
Randolph can find something else to
reality yeah good luck though Randolph
ye oh my god I do out there to enjoy a
podcast so you and your funny little
friend a very gutters name the other go
bottom story today 69 is facing multiple
charges including racketeering in there
and that's why we brought in our US law
correspondent and resident of the true
gid podcast criminal expert because it
used to be one yeah excellent thanks for
coming it
you're welcome fighting back on I'm
listening to all these YouTube channels
saying
Takashi's gonna get a life sentence yeah
he's gonna be going to trial late next
year
he's already snitching his move moved to
a prison for snitches it's all complete
and utter [__] nobody know I'm
talking about on this case because wow
they've never been facing a RICO case
and you have I was facing the exact same
charges as Takashi in the Arizona state
prison system plan so let's just start
by explaining what Rico means what does
Rica mean people can't even pronounce it
no Racketeer Influenced and Corrupt
Organizations right basically when
you're a gangster so this was introduced
to take down the Mafia
you got Paul Castellano prancing around
his replica of the White House and his
silk pajamas he's not actually
physically committing any crimes
the foot soldiers at the street level
are hoisting trucks extorting people
moving money laundering so how do we
nail Paul in his silk pajamas we
introduce a law that makes him
responsible for everybody else's in this
organization and that's how Takashi six
lanes we derived into this because here
in a boss he isn't even a foot soldier
he's just read their famous guy on the
side of shouts trail with Frank Sinatra
of this world yeah they've brought him
in look a pop you don't know me so I
what is likely to happen to him at this
point right now what's he what's he
going through became so within this Rico
structure my charges of conspiracy crime
syndicate continuous criminal
organization so regarding the crime
syndicate they give everybody a letter
in terms of order of importance so
because he is so high-profile they're
gonna have him near the apex there are
three strategies I have that he can
employ to get out of this without
snitching and not serve over ten years
which is what happened in my case so if
you're also in this situation at home
maybe you're going through a RICO case
yourself is highly likely at some point
in your life then you can follow we were
real so this on how to beat Rico yeah
because they did it in Batman will they
do it here first strategy United defense
the guys have got the money in the crime
syndicate pay for a high-priced lawyer
he then gives his instructions to all
the other lawyers representing all of
the other co-defendants and you've got a
United defense and that then prevents
everybody from snitching right okay what
what are the other things you can do in
this point strategy number two don't
snitch because weapons is the prosecutor
right now if the cash is seen murder
conspiracy weapons charges that's right
to Fright a multiple life sentences
highlight on they're trying to scare the
[__] out of these guys without actually
giving them the legal discovery yet
they're lawyers right now we'll just be
borrowing through all that legal
discovery figuring out what they're up
against so to say that takashi snitched
already when it's night doesn't even
know where it's up against is good
not a nonsense right they need to know
it up again so they're just using these
skirt tactics of say nice nests life
sentence murder beef to try and break
people down from the get-go but the
lawyers will come back and say hey
here's what we're up against here's what
you're looking at we're gonna negotiate
this down there's no way Takashi if he's
not got prior federal or state felony
convictions he's got misdemeanors so
aggravate the sense of it there's no way
he's gonna be serving a life sentence in
court is when they're they were all in
court he pled not guilty shot me the
head honcho he basically turns around
and starts shouting and sending a
message to everyone in the in that group
of the loud sin we don't bend we don't
break it's [__] true way and he
shouts that in front of the judge what
was he doing in saying that this is a
misguided announcement revolving around
strategy too because there's a time and
a place to get this information to you
co-defendants right number three is
courtroom decorum that's right basically
kiss that judge is off because he's the
guy who can send you away for life if he
feels disrespected do you think he's
trying to tell six-lane to stick with us
and don't snitch or is that more of a
threat that way to do it they Wow bad
way to do it and there's other ways to
do this which I employed strategically
that wouldn't piss the Georgia
so for example I was in towers jail in
my first year loads of my co-defendants
are in there we go to religious services
Ross sat on the back roads at religious
services I'm giving them the latest news
from my lawyer's God spreading the word
on the develop spreading the good Lord's
word religious oh they got so sick of me
doing this after a year in
medium-security she doubled my bail to
1.5 million dollars cash only so I would
be automatically reclassified to maximum
security to a different facility from my
co-defendants which is exactly what
they've gone to to catch right chemistry
I mean it snitching at the end of the
day what's gonna happen is these
products accusers are like car
salespeople they're about life sentence
gets negotiated down right but every
time someone greets to cooperate they
have more bargaining power and you gotta
get up in front of the judge and this is
not snitching you've just got to say I
plead guilty
to such and such an offense akashi's
case he can say is that got murdered
that is a mitigating circumstance there
are two types of circumstances that can
increase or decrease your sentence and
aggravating circumstance getting in
front of the judge and saying to your
co-defendants I'm not going to fall I'm
not gonna bend is an aggravating
circumstance he's gonna pop your
sentence
all right mitigating circumstances are
things that the judge will take into
consideration to reduce your sentence
right Takashi needs to get like all
these people right in lettuces it George
saying like he was just out as a young
person his dad died trying to grow this
business
classy 69 but tops my three strategies
he's gonna get anywhere from a 5 to 10
years since these felonies will be
reduced so that you won't have to serve
a hundred percent of his sentence so we
could see him getting out within about
five year period assault am i right in
thinking that this is gonna this could
might not even go to trial is what you
were saying it's not gonna go to trial
all these people saying Takashi's gonna
go to trial next year it's completely
nuts and answers these cases don't go to
trial they end up in plea bargains he is
now a target for the gangs and it's
complex because he's half Mexican half
Puerto Rican but he's claiming Bloods so
how nitrate Bloods came out of Rikers
Island prison gang black gang so if
there's an issue but he's denounced art
recently so there could be what in their
vengeance watch you might announce that
to cause a paper trail to help his case
he might have seen this was coming
there's no coincidence that he did the
breakfast club a week before he or he
got arrested but they claim and there's
there's evidence of this that when he
came out and said I don't want to be a
part of this [__] anymore that they were
tough in the phones of the Israeli gang
and they had been saying we're going to
kill him basically
gonna kill them because it's denounced
us now now they might have just been
saying that because they know they're
getting tough all the more likely thing
is that part of this is true I think
it's getting hyped up because series
gangsters were gonna kill someone don't
speak about it on the phone they just
come up behind you on a dark night
ballon alley and put one behind you yeah
how does the money move around well
obviously he's got no money in prison
and the people in prison have got no
money they can't exactly hold up as you
take Cod yeah how do you move up here oh
well Takashi is now an ATM forever
prison he's at but the money doesn't
actually come out of his mouth compared
to ours doesn't yeah so Takashi's people
on the street would have a black bag of
sports bag with some cash in it will be
handed over to the gang leaders people
on the street and that would pay for his
safety Wow well that's been great
analysis from our man Shana
we'll get you back to talk more about I
will do a podcast keeping him for
another yeah if you want to check out
more of short stuff there's the book
link sorry the description below
he'll be covering most of on his channel
appreciate you all supporting my channel
bring hundred thousand subscribers now
stronger Jovi and Lauren SIA lighting a
fire under it preacher that guys get a
beer thanks Sean Cheers in other news
YouTube rewinds back it's back every
year
who's that oh my godness youtuber Will
Smith I give Will Smith a puss yeah
because he is legendary yeah if we will
we're lucky as youtubers to have him on
this platform so I gave a purpose we
ninja we all know ninja I feel like he
is one of the few people in this I know
how did they get twitch staff
ninja in this get offended
when you think of this year in the posse
on YouTube I think of two main things
without a doubt without a doubt YouTube
box and boom Shane Dawson document where
are these things bigger to us than they
were to the Hispanic and kpop community
maybe maybe shut the [__] up white boy
okay YouTube rewind is supposed to be a
recap of what happened on YouTube this
year not about pandering there's a
[__] liberal Cox don't call them Cox
I know him I you know Casey is actually
going I don't know who anyone is bad for
Casey because to me Casey he inspired a
generation I think he's a leaf all right
Casey nice that is elite level YouTube
I'm guessing I can only surmise the only
thing that they are trying to pay a
tribute to this in the video they're in
a forest genius I think that's the only
thing I think I can say they're wanting
us to remember about the sins
YouTube left us hanging of God
Casey you're better than this me it
should have said no look at his little
face sweep at him he is look at that
little face put your glasses back garden
have some self-respect kisser ID here
for foxing that jacket no of all the
British youtubers make a [__] diaper
I need good podcast to see you because
is there anyone you want to call out you
know that was an iconic lightning
reading why not me yeah I mean at the
end of the day you see you can erase
login and JJ from your [__] year of
rewind but the facts are the [__]
money run YouTube this year Shane Dawson
run YouTube this yes and I creamed off
of the three of them yeah you creamed on
the first just give me the cream right
you can I just say after the year I've
had and I'm not in this year I'd never
you're never gonna know they're like
this guy is not safe Malcolm who are
these Korean people that were there
Korean people you're not gonna know them
do you not watch Korean content don't be
so ignorant
it's Hardy be a [__] dog the dog who
is this [__] dog how it was a youtube
comment it if it I did the jaw LFA I did
the the logon for they bought was kiss I
yeah
great podcasts Arkwright for depression
ooh but that was the end of the game I
mean what if you can't get in the
YouTube rewind crying for depression
what what you do
yeah I think you do [__] charity just
a quick question I'm not doing charity
just to be fair though did you cry
towards the end of 2017 what was it was
January was it it was in it was this
year really this has been my year yeah
then they get into the cartoony bit of
God then they get back to the camp
forest then they talk about how grateful
they are and then let paw is in the
video yeah all in there that is the only
football soccer live show worth watching
on YouTube is the kickoff do they have
us in the football bit no 2018 each was
football the biggest livestream
surrounding the World Cup and we weren't
in this video appreciate me you [__]
ASML made it right yes I mom made it in
they've got a lot of content creators
jemelle isn't in this I will be furious
jemelle one fine oh I like a few of the
air so I'll go so I'm interested to who
comes a warning yeah these are all the
SMR channels that Bryan's been watching
so well not only is our actual ear so
more youtubers right we're representing
here some more who with people who don't
do this and love with you one thing I
will say is if they had have bought the
relay ASMR youtubers then they would
have had to bring all the pedophiles
that come with them so that would have
been tricky that would have been hard no
girl no there's a lot of pedophiles and
sexual perverts the watch ASMR back in
the forest for longer the control of the
bushes or to have someone just not
having a good time
Peter been at it again I am all for
animal rights
I'm all for animals being protected
because animals from time to time do
need protection and you know what Zuma
topless some of them are treated badly
alright what we need to do Brian is stop
using and I'm all for this cause aunty
animal language or the animals
completely ignorant of everything we're
saying about me because we're gonna hurt
their feelings no I think
do a ditch truck on us I don't that
[__] dog in the [__] YouTube
bloody rewind
imagine if that's how you get your fame
this year Peter tweeted this words
matter and as our understanding of
social justice and they've already
triggered you there revolves our
language evolves along with it here's
how to remove species isms from our
daily conversations right so killing two
birds with one stone
what do you say what instead that's
right Brian feed two birds with one
stone that's it's the same phrase I
think if Schoen is quite a big thing for
two birds to eat isn't it now all I'm
Steve is probably gonna feed four or
five my anger for this is why don't the
birds get a scone each instead of a beat
a dead horse
what would you say that's right Brian
feed the dead horse
sorry feed the feed the fed horse with
the feet of the horses already food why
feed him again your forced feeding a
horse you [__] pricks right bring
home the bacon
what would you say instead I'm what
what's wrong with bacon well that's dead
pig what is wrong with barracks right
Brian bring home the bagels it's the
same phrase how much money are Peter
take enough people per you I think
they're donations yeah yes you
supportively look after animals these
people are you instead they're spending
the time [__] not in this show to be
fair dish if you're donut in the Peter
stop this shows my advice to you here's
my advice spend money on other animal
charities because this lot tossing it
off they've only thought of it from a
middle-class perspective when I see the
phrase kill two birds with one stone
I don't instantly think muscat and kill
two birds with one stone
I implore you to try yeah exactly a one
bird with a stone you've got exactly the
American base for lead yeah when they
say beat the dead horse
the phrase is actually flogging a dead
horse and this phrase is often preceded
by the by the word don't so if you over
tell a joke you go mate don't close
their doors because what they mean is
the horse is already dead yeah you've
really killed the joke so actually what
my words are doing is encouraging people
not to beat the horse have you beaten
it's dead already it's not gonna feel it
so don't worry about it
why is the whole state natural causes
old age exactly in other news in the
world of YouTube Vic's star finally went
through with it he got the transactional
surgery noise he's moved house oh I
[Music]
always wondered why Simon lived outside
of London I knew as a matter of time
that went before they moved into London
because all those uber rides for the
rats and the dates yeah they're gonna
cost you the other one of three one of
three gets a lot of plaques nowadays you
should brush more mate he's got the
shortest dick who can fit a bottle in
there who's got the most space in their
shorts boom will because notoriously the
Eurostar stops you taking alcohol on
Austria yes what a mission these guys
buy [__] dollar crazy guy con kook
but probably grown up a little bit I've
grown up so much
I've got pot noodles but I've got
drawers that light I've grown up a lot
I have grown up so much let me give the
drawers get them Vic I want to hear a
story about every one of the bottles in
this Tesco and they said you will not
take that bottle and I said I will give
you money for it and they said you can
take like a Jedi Maitri you will let me
live with this bottle you I will take
this
that is good I would love it if you if
you look closer you read the comments
because they encourage I get the feeling
that's what we could do for you yeah I
think there'd be a lot of those you fat
prick I hate you
Sunderland want you to die red and white
[__] magpie bastard you always say when
you're gonna do more P I don't ever
known don't know where it goes but it's
only me and I walk alone it makes him
look like a suave educated man I walk my
shadows only one books beside me this is
a long kiss again
how can I stretch this to ten minutes
not a national few minutes of piano
leave its this is actually a full
concert is one of the few skinny
youtubers that you like yeah it's true
ceiling ceilings that's not the roof one
thing I hate is when people miss label
architecture it's not different it was
all office just so-so room with a
lightness it's a white room with a light
you know it was so that the environment
didn't change too much he's kept the
wall lights the kids know where the wall
lights are they know what they mean the
world lights mean gaming they just
printed the word sidemen on the side of
a stock BC custom side the end piece
they literally went it's Adele but if we
just put saipin on this side then no oh
no no look that was by the way if you
want your own specialist true Geordie PC
be sure to just take a [__] on the
screen
so basically Neil deGrasse Tyson famous
scientist you've probably seen him on
the jaw and podcast if you've got good
taste in podcasts this guy is a genius
I think he's usually seen as a fountain
of information in terms of space science
all of that good [__] it's a great
public voice he's a great speaker he's
an intelligent guy he's funny he's
entertaining
and he's very good at bringing education
to life and and making it fun and
entertaining so Neil deGrasse Tyson has
been accused of sexual misconduct right
but on the good side he's released a
statement it's sort of clear all up that
it was a misunderstanding for a variety
of reasons most justified some
unjustified men accused of sexual
impropriety in today's me to climate are
presumed to be guilty by the court of
public opinion right which is fair I've
recently been publicly accused of sexual
misconduct these accusations have
received a fair amount of press in the
past four years I was unaccompanied by
my reactions but basically he's saying
if he stays silent people are just think
he's guilty right he's coming over to
talk about it 2009 a colleague at a well
attend after conference social gathering
came up and asked for photographs she
was wearing scaevola stress the tattooed
solar system extending up her arm right
and well I don't explicitly remember
searching for Pluto at the top of her
shoulder it is surely something I would
have done in that situation as we all
know I have a professional history with
the demotion of Pluto which had occurred
officially in the press just three years
earlier I was reported to have a groomer
by searching opor dress when this was
simply searched under the covered part
of her shoulder of a sleeveless dress
right but the way it can be read written
about in the headlines is looked up my
dress wear as well the sleeve of a dress
is not really clever I only just learned
nine years after in brackets that she
thought this behavior to be creepy that
was never my intent and I'm deeply sorry
to have made her feel that way had I
have been told of her discomfort in the
moment I would have offered an apology
in my mind's eye I'm a friendly
accessible guy but going forward I can
be more sensitive to people's personal
space so that's
all perfectly explained if she's
feasible ms maybe guy didn't know quite
about what boundaries some people yeah
and he's the note right on me nerds
might do something like that yeah fair
enough then I'm reading this incident
ago this apology or whatever and that
was summer of 2018 incident and I'm like
oh it's when the evidence stopped
mounting that you start feeling like oh
is this some Oh read the incident okay
give him give him a give him a fair
chance
good give him a fair chance kill two
birds with one stone named Pete I would
say while filming this past summer I had
a female production assistant assigned
to me so across the many weeks of
shooting she and I spent upwards of a
hundred hours in one-on-one conversation
we became so friendly everyone she knew
would get a hug from her in the morning
or whatever when she'd walk in she in
apparently he said no like I prefer a
handshake but the thing is he said if I
hug you
I might just want more but the thing is
if you spent a hundred hours with
someone you should probably be able to
say that without being taken as a joke
maybe but even then you sort of thinking
mmm
that he sort of cross the line in a way
there's ooh did some on a few occasions
he said that I invited her to some wine
and cheese at my place upon dropped me
off for work no pressure I serve wine
and cheese often as I freely chose to
come by for wine and cheese and I was
delighted but she was on her way home
two hours later so I just came in had
some cheese anyway she went then [__]
off yeah
afterwards she came into my office and
told me she was creeped out by the wine
and cheese evening she viewed the invite
as an attempt to seduce her he's really
leaving out a lot of what went down did
you say to her like fancy a [__] in your
ass you know like I don't think you know
what seduction is no but the point is to
me if she's saying that was
inappropriate I don't think she's saying
you choosing cheese and wine is
inappropriate and he's leaving out any
of the conversation he's making who's
going to camembert wasn't the right
choice I never touched her until I shook
her hand on departure right on that
occasion yeah I had offered a special
handshake
one I learned from a native elder on
reservation lad at the edge of the Grand
Canyon you extend your thumb forward
during the handshake to feel the other
person's vital spirit energy
the pulse sexual is it nothing sexual
not a sexual shy is it now accepted my
apology and I assured her that I didn't
I had known she was if I'd known she was
uncomfortable I would have apologized on
the spot but anyway you're thinking
yourself
alright 2009 incident 2018 incident
reading the statement [__] hell
early 1980s often and that's where I
start to get worried
all this time in the early nineteen
eighties when he was studying or
whatever people in the flat or a straw a
graduate student from a more recent
entering class I remember being intimate
only a few times with her at her
apartment but the chemistry wasn't there
so the relationship faded quickly signs
upon a few years later I ran into her
pregnant more than thirty years later as
my visibility level took another jump I
read a freshly posted blog accusing me
of drugging and raping a woman I did not
recognize by either thought or name
turned out by the same person I dated
briefly in graduate school she changed
her name and lived an entire life
married with children before this
accusation now he drops this statement
to cover the three allegations that he's
received right and on drop in the
statement almost to the minute another
allegation has come out right we're
gonna keep an eye on this because he is
an important guy and I do think it is as
he says fail to judge him on the
evidence do you know what I mean because
this might all be [__] but he's an
important block in his industry so we'll
keep an eye on this on the true news
Astra and hopefully it's all bollocks
that poor choice of words file this
under steroid Thailand and the name Dan
yes that's right
it's steroid infection in Thailand with
Dan promise a lot of bodybuilding this
guy obviously spent a lot of his life
trying to build this body up he's used
the gear and apparently some of it was
dodgy from Thailand who'da thunk it yeah
I mean he has actually called himself
Dan the bodybuilder in Thailand true
Jordy the youtuber in London watching
Dan the bodybuilder in Thailand
basically as you can see the the video
starts with some pictures of his
infection pretty bad in his leg
and I'm pretty popular in the
bodybuilding world as you can imagine
because they're all sort of frightened
that this could happen to them yeah
[Music]
instantly you can see how much emotions
in this poor guy's face blossom I'm not
sure why yeah this is horrible
is such critical condition in the title
here yeah [__] pinging my leg that's
spreading through me and I need more
surgeries you can't imagine that the
health care in Colombia is exactly the
best that you will it may be preferable
to Thailand Bosco of those oh yeah he's
you can't even get on a plane with this
[__] you might die like that there is a
GoFundMe page for this guy at the bottom
of this video if you want to donate or
and bless him he's obviously just a guy
who's working out he injected some dirty
gear in him and now his life's just
being [__] ripped apart I think we're
gonna need to end this video on a more
positive note right if I can just yeah
tick over here for a second to take over
there because that is a pretty badly
you've just looked away while I search
for this yes I don't know if you'll
approve of what are you just a video I
seen the other day it really cheered me
up so if we could just watch this again
here we go this is a Ouija you just
watching us for lawrence lays around by
the beach just i know you love it look
at that one why
it's just you literally looped it
yourself now don't erection as well
unbelievable right thanks for watching
today's show it's been good to watch
throughs news with you if you got any
suggestions this week for the news and
we're supposed to talk about next week
if you could do our chops for us that
would be I'll be ideal well public
research isn't it public subscribe and
like of course all that reminds me
globba cool I've got I've got your
birthday present happy birthday thanks
buddy can I just say it yeah the
reasoning behind this gift is Lauren
sister you know he's getting old right I
wanted to get him something that made
him feel young again I really want to
know what it is
well open this Wow and you really wrap
this really well someone might help this
did really I'm a good bond
it's a PlayStation classic the original
PlayStation oh good reboot that's
actually a great present you're a really
thoughtful friend and I just say you've
ruined what my Christmas present was
gonna be to you I actually got myself on
this really good spy for some people in
the comments there has been a lot of
critique about this because it is a bit
quite a basic system yeah of course for
us it's just memories yeah I mean it's
them reason I'm not expecting away that
from us thanks for watching anyway and
we'll see us later
bye bye